he is the pride of tennessee and has
been crushing it at comedy clubs across
the country for decades henry cho brings
his comedy show to the south point this
weekend he joins us now hey thanks for
having me good to see you oh great to
see you as always the pride of tennessee
my man i am the proud of tennessee you
know tennessee's the volunteer state
they can't make you live there
there you go right off the bat
that's what he doesn't he's got people
laughing dropping the cameras that's it
do you remember your first show
yes you know i was in college and my
buddy asked me hey you want to what are
you going to do with your life i said
i said i'm going to try stand-up comedy
he goes you're not funny i go i know but
i think i can do it so we actually wrote
my set on the way
to the comedy club i entered this
competition on a monday night
and i won
and they hired me i started working on
wednesday and i dropped out of college
on friday so stay in school young people
yeah but i did that was
over three decades ago wow yeah but you
took some time off like 10 years for
your kids right i did you know i wanted
to raise them i was just telling we were
just talking about this uh uh
yeah i i coached my kids baseball
basketball when they were young
i'm probably the only comedian that can
say they did that and i was home a lot
and i didn't miss a friday night
football game my high school game my son
played i missed two maybe
and uh in four years so
yeah that was my priority yeah because i
wasn't going to get married and have
kids if i wasn't going to be the dad i
thought i should be and
so now that they're out of the house i
don't care about them anymore so i'm
back
he's back on the wait that's what i'm
about to show it's your family you're
clean you keep things clean clean humor
it is clean yeah you know it's adult
humor but it's clean it's clean and
short yeah yeah i mean well see i'm a i
always said this i'm a christian who's a
comedian i'm not a christian comedian
because christian comedians aren't funny
so that's a joke okay they're funny do
your kids know what you do i mean they
know what you do but they know they
realize how famous you are in the career
that you're at or you know it it still
astounds them sometimes because you know
i was jus i'm just dad
and i have like i said you know i pulled
way back
because you know i was riding it pretty
high there and i got married had we
decided to have a family all that stuff
until
i don't know about
four or five months ago you know i
started out with all the big boys who
are super duper famous yeah and we're
still pals so out of the blue
uh
i get an email
and it's adam sandler asking me to voice
over
a bus driver in his nickelodeon movie
right and i hadn't seen adam in years uh
every time i've seen him you know we
always just catch up like like it was
yesterday but my kids you know i just
show my kids the email and they're like
wow
okay
okay that's the real deal okay dad that
one's okay all these old guys vince gill
willie nelson
yeah you got adam sandler okay you're at
the south point this weekend it's been a
blast to see you back doing your thing
doing stand up
uh it's so much fun i am so happy to be
back doing you know i was home for 18
months and i love my family but not
every day you guys are making some get
back making some money college to pay
for the kids right i love it south point
two uh two shows to one tonight one
tomorrow perfect and time for golfing
this weekend you can see henry cho
tonight and tomorrow night 7 30 p.m at
the south point hotel tickets start at
25
and you get them online through
ticketmaster thanks so much buddy
appreciate it thanks for having me again